jan schäfer hat den koalitionsvertrag
jetzt fast schon durchgearbeitet wird
muss ich sagen hier in aller schnelle
seither auch sendungen sind was sind für
dich die markantesten punkte die
überraschendsten punkte vielleicht auch
dinge die man vorher anders erwartet
hatte also ich glaube beim thema klima
da herrscht jetzt wenig überraschung
dass genau das drinsteht was auch im
sondierungs papier stand dass
beispielsweise der kohleausstieg
vorgezogen werden soll nicht 20 38 wie
bisher sondern idealerweise so heißt es
im koalitionsvertrag
20.30 ob das klappt ist eine ganz andere
frage und was ganz wichtig ist
deutschland soll bereits 2030 80 prozent
des stroms aus
erneuerbaren energien beziehen können
bisher war das ziel 65 prozent der
stellen wir uns vor november tag wie
heute heute morgen beispielsweise 72
prozent des stroms kam eben doch aus
konventioneller energien die kernkraft
wie kohle dessen berauben wir uns ja und
da geht es dann weiter geht um das thema
jobs beispielsweise wer minijob tätig
ist oder einem minijob der soll künftig
deutlich mehr hinzuverdienen können auch
der mindestlohn soll steigen aber
achtung da ein unterschied zum
regierungs papier da stand ja drin im
ersten jahr will die ampel koalition den
mindestlohn in einem schritt auf 12 euro
erhöhen von derzeit knapp 10 euro das
steht jetzt so nicht mehr drin der
mindestlohn könnte theoretisch also erst
2023 oder 20 24 steigen und dann immer
wichtig für alle beschäftigten aber auch
für alle rentner am ende zahlen die
heute beschäftigten das was die rentner
an rente bekommen da gibt es zwei
wichtige änderungen zum einen sollen die
renten künftig nicht mehr ganz so stark
steigen etwas was die spd in der letzten
regierung noch durchgesetzt hat da wurde
die rentenformel geändert dass es wird
jetzt wieder aufgehoben da hat sich die
fdp deutlich durchgesetzt und etwas was
sehr interessant ist wir wissen ja dass
immer mehr teile der rente besteuert
werden also viele rentner klagen ja im
alter mensch so viel rente geht ab weil
ich plötzlich steuern zahlen muss dieser
ganze prozess der besteuerung der wird
verlangsamt bedeutet die rentner haben
am ende mehr von ihrer rente zur
verfügung also wie heißt es so schön
mehr netto vom brutto aber was würdest
du sagen wie gehen die ministerposten
aus beziehungsweise an wen geht welcher
ministerposten da tun sich die politiker
irgendwann noch schwer da genaue angaben
zu machen
also für mich erst mal klar das die fdp
eigentlich der gewinner ist dieser
aufteilung dass christian der sich
durchgesetzt hat als finanzminister dass
sie weitere wichtige zukunft ressorts
bekommen haben nämlich bildung verkehr
und justiz damit hätte ich in der fülle
nicht gerechnet dass die fdp sich neben
dem finanzministerium also insgesamt
vier ministerien hat durchsetzen können
bei den grünen sind es die klassischen
ressorts robert habeck wird vizekanzler
wir im rat schon gesehen er ist jetzt
derjenige der als erster spricht
annalena baerbock war dann irgendwie als
670 dran die wird sich auf das außenamt
konzentrieren wird außenministerin das
keine allzu große überraschung
ansonsten ist es bei den grünen und der
spd im detail noch ein bisschen offen
die spd muss man sagen hat neben dem
kanzleramt zwei wichtige
schlüsselressorts die innen das
innenministerium und das
verteidigungsministerium und das ist
schon eine menge gerade beim
innenministerium das war sehr sehr lange
in unionshand der letzte spd
innenminister otto schily also das ist
lange her das wird interessant zu sehen
sein wie die spd da versuchen wird auch
diese ressorts umzug erfahrungen gibt es
denn so ein streit ums gesundheitsamt
also gefühlt hat man ja jetzt schon
mögliche namen gehört aber irgendwie
will sich darauf keiner festlegen warum
ist das so das gesundheitsministerium
wurde hin und hergewechselt auch bei den
verhandlungen am ende wollte es niemand
so richtig haben weil es ist natürlich
wie wir sehen an jens spahn eins der
schwierigsten ministerien und selbst
wenn man da einen der erfahrensten
hinsetzt auch dann bedeutet das noch
dass der- oder diejenige der buhmann der
nation werden kann nachher einsparen
wenn es dann wieder nicht klappt mit den
impfungen wenn der lockdown kommt wenn
die zahlen hoch gehen also da hat
erstmal niemand wirklich lust drauf und
jetzt ist die frage die spd soll es
bekommen aber wer wird bei der spd und
da tut sich ein streit auf um karl
lauterbach man hört dass er unbedingt
will der wird jetzt gesund gegangen dass
wir reden sagen kann laut
gesundheitsminister
also man muss noch dazu sagen aber
möglicherweise karl lauterbach allein
aus platzgründen dann rausgenommen wird
ja auch nrw eben kommt und eine frau
vielleicht dann gesundheitsministerin
wird ich finde es sehr spannend
ist ein ganz spannender kampf eine gute
nachricht das sagt der koalitionsvertrag
auch kann zumindest der nächste
gesundheitsminister verkünden denn
krankenkassen sollen künftig auch
verhütungsmittel zahlen können das heißt
die kondome gibt es von der kasse ich
glaube das wird viele menschen in dem
land freuen und dass wir zumindest eine
nachricht wenn ein finnland
gesundheitsminister schon massiv unter
druck ist während der korona pandemie
dann ist das vielleicht etwas wo er für
ein bisschen freude so lasst uns doch
mal weil es doch ein historischer moment
war jetzt nicht so sehr über boston
reden und die einzelheiten des vertrages
analysieren wir gleich auch noch mal ich
möchte nochmal auf die stimmung zurück
kommen die wir da gerade erlebt haben
deshalb haben wir sie ja auch übertragen
eine lernende politik will er machen hat
robert habeck zum beispiel gesagt hofft
man dass sie schon ein bisschen viel
wissen nicht allzu viel lernen müssen
aber christian lindner hat gesagt die
spd und die grünen können stolz auf das
ergebnis sein dass sie haben das ist
natürlich auch sehr grosszügig und olaf
scholz werde ein starker bundeskanzler
sein das war ja wirklich eine sehr
harmonische atmosphäre wo man nur die
zwischentöne hören musste und über allem
stand dieses wort respekt dass wir auch
im vertrag stehen soll
man hat versucht einfach das zu
inszenieren was die union nicht
hinbekommen hat über so viele jahre
vertraulichkeit in den gremiensitzungen
man hat versucht besonders respektvoll
miteinander umzugehen wobei ich fand jan
dieser satz von lindner nett gemeint
gewesen sein für mich klang ist aber
auch so ein bisschen ja ich habe so viel
durchgesetzt ja und da so ein bisschen
gönnerhafte geste ja ihr könnt trotzdem
stolz darauf sein was sie rausgeholt hat
weiß ich wie du es also da hast du glaub
ich vollkommen recht am ende beginnt
jetzt für bis auf christian lindner
zumindest für die spitze der spd und vor
allem für die beiden parteichefs der
grünen die schwierigste phase überhaupt
dieser koalitionsverhandlungen sie
müssen nämlich das ergebnis bei ihrer
basis bei ihren mitgliedern bei ihren
delegierten verkaufen und da ist
natürlich einsatz von christian lindner
sicherlich nicht gemeint ihr habt doch
eigentlich gute dinge durchgesetzt wir
wissen aber auch an der basis der grünen
an der basis der spd der ist die fdp
nicht plötzlich der allerbeste freund
nein das ist immer noch eine partei mit
der man eigentlich gar nicht so gerne
etwas zu tun haben möchte von daher ein
vergiftetes lob und wenn sich auf
einsatz noch mal auch von saskia esken
der co-vorsitzenden spd konzentrierte ja
gesagt ja hier hat verhandelt was
zusammenpasst dann frage ich mich doch
eigentlich warum ist man denn im sommer
also vor wenigen monaten noch wie die
kesselflicker aufeinander losgegangen da
gab es beschimpfungen von seiten von
saskia essen genauer ab und sagt die
ampel ausgeschlossen kevin kühnert genau
richtung fdp auch speziell zur person
christine also paul hat gerade gesagt
das war natürlich eine schöne show die
wir heute gesehen haben und jetzt gucken
wir doch mal wie lange hält eigentlich
dieser glamour der versucht wurde heute
zu versprühen aber war eine show war das
wirklich nur eine show ist da nicht
wirklich auch ein neuer spirit ein neuer
geist zumindest versucht worden
auszusenden ansonsten wäre nichts davon
ehrlich gemeint gewesen was da im großen
respekt übereinander gesagt ja aber die
frage ist ja schon warum ist eigentlich
drei wochen nur vier wochen vor einer
bundestagswahl eine ampelkoalition so
gut wie nicht möglich weil man sagt man
schließlich gegeneinander aus und vier
wochen später oder acht wochen später
also ist es das was am besten
zusammenpasst dass das stimmt ja nicht
und das wissen wir auch hier müssen sich
drei parteien zusammen raufen das haben
sie sicherlich ganz ordentlich auch
gemacht und jetzt geht es darum auch
dieses land gut zu regieren aber dass
das jetzt eine liebesheirat ist das
glaube ich bestreitet hier würde niemand
an diesem tisch bestreiten und wie will
man haben und einander gelernt haben sie
ja gesagt in den verhandlungen annalena
baerbock hat mit dem bild gesagt wenn
sie 06 sehen und wir neuen dann kann man
es eben von beiden seiten aus betrachten
ja ich finde auch die können so viel
sagen wie sie wollen jetzt am ende geht
es darum was kommt da raus was machen
sie jetzt wie sitze dann im kabinett aus
was passiert bei corona was passiert bei
umwelt mir ist eigentlich als bürger und
beobachtet ziemlich wurscht was sie
wieder an einer pressekonferenz erzählt
weil das glaube ich erst mal sowieso
nicht von daher denke ich am ende muss
jetzt das was dort in dem vertrag steht
umgesetzt werden und ich glaube dass ich
so wie jan da werden sie noch heftig
streiten und wer einmal in eine szene
reingucken die nämlich jetzt gerade auf
der pressekonferenz war dein olaf scholz
hat einen historischen satz gesagt
die ampel steht
spd grüne und fdp haben sich in den
verhandlungen auf einen gemeinsamen
koalitionsvertrag verständigt und damit
auf ein neues regierungsbündnis
diesen vertrag legen wir nun unseren
parteien zur abstimmung vor die ampel
steht das sind die drei worte die
wirklich jetzt wir haben sie auch online
bei bild.de noch mal ganz große garde
aufgeschrieben die ampel steht was sind
so hat euch das auch überrascht das ist
jetzt so schnell ging oder war das
absehbar also der termin war ja
eigentlich immer anvisiert olaf scholz
hat schon vor wochen erklärt er möchte
wenn alles gut geht eigentlich in der
woche nach nikolaus das ist dann siebter
achter neunter dezember zum
bundeskanzler gewählt werde und dann
kann man einfach runterzählen und kann
sagen okay wie muss das eigentlich
funktionieren die parteitage bei fdp und
spd müssen zustimmen und die grünen
haben von anfang an gesagt dass sie ihre
mitglieder abstimmen lassen wollen über
den koalitionsvertrag so und das kann
man ja es gibt einen gewissen
zeitkorridoren wenn man den zurück
rechnet dann war eigentlich klar dass
diese woche dieser termin sein muss an
dem der koalitionsvertrag
präsentiert und vier wochen das ist
schon schnell das ist richtig aber das
hat öfter schon mal gegeben für den
anderen konstellation aber vier wochen
zu verhandeln und dafür auch noch die
wochen der sanierung das ist jetzt auch
ein zeitrahmen der jetzt nicht
ultraschnell ist da schauen wir uns
jetzt mal an was in diesen vier wochen
in diesem vertrag reingekommen ist ich
bin ja anderer meinung als du im übrigen
paul ist erstmal nicht egal ist was sie
da sagen sondern ich finde es ist denn
in dieser zeit natürlich auch wichtig
ein signal des aufbruchs und der
erneuerung zu senden aber trotzdem kommt
es natürlich darauf an was dann am ende
tatsächlich drin steht wir haben unsere
experten hier bei uns im studio
sebastian geisler lydia rosenfelder
wallschule und philippi adorf und wir
haben sie mal zugeordnet den wichtigen
themen die für die menschen jetzt
wichtig sind klima familie bildung
flüchtlinge migration krone und
gesundheit was davon steht wie im
koalitionsvertrag und vor allem wer hat
sich durchgesteckt durchgesetzt um dann
am ende festzustellen so scholz ist
deutschland wir werden das so das sage
ich noch mal kurz vorab zur erklärung
dann hier an unserer grafik verfolgen
und dann gibt's punkte für
beispielsweise urlaubs scholz oder die
fdp für die grünen und am ende sehen wir
dann wie viel punkte jeder hat und wer
sich hier am meisten durchgesetzt hat
und wie scholz deutschland ist also
fangen wir an vielleicht ladies first
mit familie und bildung lydia ja die spd
nimmt einen neuen anlauf einen in der
letzten legislaturperiode gescheitertes
projekt doch durchzusetzen die
verankerung von kinderrechten im
grundgesetz
da hat sie sich abgekämpft an der union
in der letzten legislaturperiode der
kompromiss wurde soweit aufgeweicht dass
dann am ende eigentlich nichts mehr
übrig war außer symbolpolitik und dann
ist es auch ganz gescheitert hier hat
sich also die spd mit einem wichtigen
für sie wichtigen prestige projekt
durchgesetzt die grünen sind auch dafür
die spd die fdp schon mal wichtig ist
aber die brauchen eine
zweidrittelmehrheit im bundestag das
heißt der punkt geht an der punkt geht
an spd und grüne und dann würde ich mal
sagen
in unserer kategorie so scholz ist
deutschland dann können wir noch mal ein
tusch gebrauchen
genau wer wann gehen wir den punkt
an die spd ja ok
weiter geht's und die grünen und die
grünen ganz
genau mitbekommen
in der bildungspolitik soll das
kooperations geburt aufgeweicht werden
das ist ganz interessant denn das
verbietet ja bisher dass der bund mit
mischt in der bildungspolitik an den
schulen und hochschulen beispielsweise
da geht es ein bisschen durcheinander
da sind die grünen zum beispiel auf
bundesebene dafür auf länder ebene wie
zb kretschmann will das nicht es ist
eigentlich allen drei wichtig dass sich
deutschland nicht weiter blamiert mit
kaputten schuldlos und maroden schulen
aber ob sie das dann eben auch so durch
bekommen und auch durch den bundesrat
bekommen durch die länderkammer das wird
interessant aber dieser punkt geht an
alle
33 gut machen wir weiter sebastian macht
gleich weiter mit dem thema klima ja
also eine vorgezogene kohleausstieg der
kommt jetzt natürlich hier nicht sehr
überraschend aber was doch schon was ist
wo ich mir direkt hier malen aus und
verzeichnen dran gemacht habe ist dass
es
das übergreifend jetzt quasi klimaschutz
betrieben werden soll als eine
querschnittsaufgabe in dem dann jedes
ressort jedes ministerium also seine
gesetzesvorhaben prüfen lassen soll auf
die vereinbarkeit mit den
klimaschutzzielen und da muss ich sagen
da ist schon eine relativ klare grüne
handschrift zu erkennen ist aber nicht
alles wenn es hier so schön heißt auch
im koalitionsvertrag formuliert wir
denken ökonomische entwicklung und
ökologische verantwortung zusammen dann
sind das stichworte wo ich sagen muss da
wird das bild immer gesagt haben die
sogenannte citrus koalition also fdp und
grüne haben sich hier sozusagen sehr
verwirklicht und verewigt man kann auch
sagen das stichwort kohleausstieg wird
ja mit einem erheblichen
transformationsprozess auch in
bestimmten regionen beispielsweise in
der lausitz einhergehen da will man an
solchen standorten jetzt auch den ausbau
als brückentechnologie von
gaskraftwerken beispielsweise
vorantreiben das kann man auch als ein
spd stichwort sehen aber insgesamt muss
ich sagen geht dieser produziert doch
überwiegend an die grünen vielleicht
noch ein bisschen an die fdp
das wäre alles andere wäre ja auch
überraschend wenn selbst wenn klima
nicht die grünen den punkt machen würden
robert habeck der ja auch der
designierte neue minister für wirtschaft
und klima ist nebenbei soll es aber auch
noch ein umweltministerium geben muss
man auch im einzelnen noch mal verstehen
ob das nicht ein bisschen doppelt
gemoppelt ist flüchtlinge und migration
ein thema wäre es uns natürlich sehr
beschäftigt wir haben alle die bilder
aus der aus belarus von der polnischen
grenze vor augen aktuell aber eben auch
flüchtlinge aus afghanistan und 2015 hat
auch noch jeder in erinnerung also ein
wichtiges zukunftsthema wie können wir
das steuern die überschrift über diesen
kapiteln müsste eigentlich lauten
deutschland macht die türen auf dass die
letzte koalition hatte das begrenzen und
das regulieren von migration zum ziel
hier werden zb diese sogenannten anker
zentren abgeschafft die zentren in denen
man den aufenthaltsstatus die als den
asylstatus prüfen sollte und
gegebenenfalls gleich wieder
zurückführen wenn es kein asyl gibt
diese zentren sollen abgeschafft werden
stattdessen haben sich die grünen da
würde ich sogar einen doppelpunkt
vergeben an verschiedenen stellen beim
aufenthaltsrecht er durchgesetzt das
wird viel einfacher jugendliche unter 27
jahren die drei jahre in deutschland
gelebt haben problemlos die sollen eine
dauer duldung und ein aufenthaltsrecht
bekommen insgesamt menschen also auch
über 27 jahren die fünf jahre hier
gelebt haben auch familien sollen ein
dauer bleiberecht bekommen und es soll
die sogenannte beschäftigungs duldung
entfristet werden dh werden
beschäftigung hat kann erstmal bleiben
und
dann sollen arbeitsverbot für diejenigen
in deutschland abgeschafft werden die
absehbar eigentlich in ihre heimatländer
zurück müssten deshalb derzeit nicht
arbeiten dürfen die dürfen dann arbeiten
damit unterfallen sie dann automatisch
wieder der beschäftigungs duldung und
können bleiberecht erwirken das heißt es
wird ein ganz großer legalisierung welle
stattfinden wer an bis am 1 am ersten
januar 20 22 in deutschland lebt und
nicht straffällig geworden ist der hat
gute chancen eine dauerhafte
aufenthalts- recht zu bekommen es sollen
alle die nach deutschland kommen einen
integrationskurs bekommen und die
meldepflichten für menschen ohne papiere
das ist ein thema was wir aus amerika
kennen soll gelockert werden das heißt
es viele die illegal hier leben und
gehen deshalb nicht zum arzt um nicht
aufzufliegen das soll künftig nicht mehr
der fall sein also da wird man milder zu
werke gehen also ich würde da zwei
punkte für die grünen vergeben und einen
für die fdp denn die fdp hat ein
punktesystem durchgesetzt mit dem
künftig
arbeitsmigranten ins land gelassen
werden können wenn sie aus berufen
stammen die deutschland dringend braucht
das alte problem in deutschland dass wir
einmal die asyl migration haben und
andererseits die arbeitsmigration
nebenher wird damit nicht aufgelöst
sondern es wird werden sozusagen beide
stränge sehr stark noch wird das andere
wichtige im moment alles überragende
thema natürlich philipp corona und
gesundheit wir haben vorhin auch schon
darüber gesprochen im koalitionsvertrag
selber findet sich gar nicht soviel dazu
ganz genau im koalitionsvertrag findet
das thema pandemie bekämpfung eigentlich
nur auf ganz wenigen zeilen stadt
deswegen hat olaf scholz gleich zu
beginn der pressekonferenz seine punkte
vorgetragen und muss sagen das sind
keine großen neuerungen dabei also
erscheint der forderung der kanzlerin
die er einen schnellen harten lockern
wollte überhaupt nicht zu folgen dass es
erst mal eine sehr klare abgrenzung eine
abgrenzung die eher klassische urlaub
scholz einfach weg sonst einfach
versteckt hinter gewissen floskeln er
macht klar bund und länder sollen
miteinander kommunizieren sollen
miteinander im austausch bleiben um
jeden tag die pandemie lage zu beraten
es wird ein pfleger bonus geben aber
abgesehen davon ist soll erstmal keine
neuen einschränkungen geben ich glaube
das ist die allerwichtigste botschaft
hat ja die kanzlerin gestern abend noch
mal bei dem eilig einberufenen treffen
als aus den verhandlungen heraus die
spitzen der parteien in der ampel
parteien noch mal ins kanzleramt gebeten
wurde offenbar noch mal versucht druck
zu machen und noch mal ganz kurzfristig
einen lock down hinzubekommen ganz genau
damit hat sie die ampel parteien auch
ordentlich unter druck gesetzt wir
wissen alle die kanzlerin setzt seit
beginn der pandemie immer wieder auf das
mittel lockdown schlägt auch immer
wieder alarm verweist auf steigende
zahlen verweist auf einen drohenden
kollaps des gesundheitssystems der
allerdings bislang zu keinem einzigen
zeitpunkt eingetreten ist olaf scholz
widersteht dem und widerspricht dem auch
und die anderen ampel parteien auch
offenbar scheint niemand mehr einen
locker und wollen die ampel hat sich ja
auch davon verabschiedet sie hat
ausgangssperren verboten sie hat
schulschließungen verboten sie möchte
auch nicht dass irgendwelche geschäfte
oder restaurants flächendeckend
geschlossen werden dabei bleibt sie
verlebt gesundheit ist nicht nur corona
sondern gesundheit wir haben es in der
korona krise festgestellt ist auch
digitalisierung als das was nötig ist um
das gesundheitssystem moderner zu machen
telemedizin was weiß ich gibt es so
gesundheit über gronau hinaus denn
ausführliche passagen also das thema
pandemie bestimmt auch weiterhin die
gesundheitspolitik übrigens auch die
wirtschaftspolitik und diverse andere
politikfelder also alles was die
pandemie jetzt gerade offengelegt hat
die schlechte digitalisierung die das
fehlende personal all das soll
aufgestockt werden also das ist das kurz
zusammengefasst das
gesundheitspolitische programm der ampel
es ist das wo gebe ich den punkt für die
gesundheit hin ich würde sagen zwischen
der spd und der fdp beide parteien
konnten sich hier durchsetzen beide
parteien konnten sich da durchsetzen so
und wenn wir es dann mal durchgehen und
noch den halben punkt vom klima den
sebastian an die fdp gegeben hat dann
sehen wir dass hier am ende in der tat
eigentlich die grünen ideen und die
liberalen ideen sich stark durchgesetzt
hat wenn ich den hier nochmal ein
bisschen an die an die seite dazu nehmen
und eigentlich weniger olaf scholz in
diesem koalitionsvertrag
steckt als christian lindner annalena
baerbock und robert habeck dafür dass
die spd immerhin die stärkste partei ist
also das ist unser ergebnis so scholz
ist deutschland gar nicht so sehr